questions
[Music]
well good evening and welcome welcome
members officers and those members of
the public that are joining us tonight
on youtube to this extraordinary full
council meeting
we'll begin on the first hour tomorrow
agenda apologies for anything
thank you chair astrologies from
councillors dart councilman's board
councillor haines councillor heckle
second item on the agenda is public
contributions
you have no public contributions so
we'll go right on to item three
declarations of interest well you all
know the score if there are any items on
the agenda please speak up when they
appear
uh item four is the agreement of the
gender items between part one and two
we do have part two items
right um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yeah
any explanation as to where the legal
challenge may come from
we'll take that under consideration
[Music]
i've
been in correspondence with cancer
bright early years today and
explained our reasoning for it being in
in part two um we are entitled to do so
if it relates to the financial affairs
or holdings of torridge district council
have any financial concern of the
council there's no figures isn't it
does relate to the land holdings of
torridge
i i don't think that we are liable for
any legal challenge and and we're
entitled to do so and furthermore within
the constitution if the head of legal
governance or the chief exec believe
it's right that it should be in part two
in addition we are entitled to do so
mr brenton
johanna yes
well we're
discussing uh
assets here
taxpayers assets
and we're representing taxpayers i
cannot understand why earthquakes
because
what secrets are if it affects the value
of the landlord
so what it's the taxpayers asset you
know if they think that we're doing it
wrong selling it off cheap that we've
done before
uh of course they're they're entitled to
uh
vote people out at the next election not
getting as they do in every other place
in the country
it's there's no secrets here to the
working group there's nothing that
involves any other private development
well i don't know what you're expecting
in terms of neighborhoods but
it's uh defines me as why why it should
look part two
you please respond the point he made is
that no decisions have been made at this
stage and tonight's meeting part two
meeting is for members to make decisions
as to what assets they would like to
consider or not and at that stage it can
be brought into
part one so it's not going to be behind
the scenes at all
yes as you can see on the agenda i mean
there is um it's only item four that
we're actually gonna be discussing
um in part two the other items will be
discussed in part one
so
specifically
thank you
did we have um some confirmation that
should any of our assets
be going to be sold off that the public
will be consulted first particularly
okay
as uh our head of legal government said
these this is an initial decision in
part to
to get more information about the
council's assets and once we've
established the full details around the
viability that we brought back before
members for consideration and start
points that they will be in part one so
this is a newly uh discussion with
members as to those particular assets
they are at this stage
assets and commercially sensitive
yeah so tonight we're not making any
decisions to actually dispose of any
assets this is
very much the preliminary discussions to
see where we will receive this counselor
um
i totally agree with the chief executive
we had a working group
not all councillors were there
and it's no use having half the
information with the council it is
sensitive it's gonna come out into the
public uh arena probably in the next
meeting
well i mean we're a capsule we're
allowed to discuss things with the sense
of it before we go
and this is probably one of those
issues thank you well it's on the agenda
that we uh
item for that we move into part two
for that from that item so we need an
agreement
sorry i didn't whereas that was
proposing secondly sorry yeah okay
thank you chair i propose we accept the
agenda
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded that we
hear the whole meeting in part one so we
need to take that first correct
so it's been proposed and been seconded
coaster bright and councillor brent and
i believe proposing second have a show
of hands all in support of that place
[Music]
okay and again
all in support of that please
[Music]
oh and again sorry
same number
yeah and abstentions
[Music]
okay item five on the agenda consider
correspondence from the business by the
chair
item six
is uh to receive a report on the
leveling up from which is pages three to
twelve and the last sean
[Music]
first thing to do is to bring uh members
attention to the stream and to the grand
reveal was the first visualization that
we've received from our architects
which
for those of you who've ever had me down
to milldock in epidural or who have seen
photos of it previously
i think presents a rather exciting
vision for the future
for this district for the economy and
then learn from that site
um
sorry to move off that kind of rather
enjoyable image
wanted to use this uh presentation just
to
raise awareness of the
change that's already happened in the
last few weeks since
we came to food council on 13th of june
and since then we've moved from river
stage one um architectural science to
layering further detail
uh into reader stage two which adrian
will talk about moving forward and what
that also does is make sure that it's
strengthening our confidence and the
figures that we're generating and also
strengthens the sense of deliverability
so this has got more detail on more
weight behind it
we spoke in the last meeting around the
detailed
operational modeling that was taking
place
and that's absolutely crucial to make
sure that we're entering this in a
position of knowledge
rather than just a headline in the sense
of hope
we have
launched a series of uh public awareness
measures which is uh involved both the
gazette and the journal covering uh the
story on the front page um
strangely in different weeks
which is slightly odd but extend the new
story so uh always positive on that
front
um
i have to say that
the level of interest within the actual
sector
uh both locally regionally and
nationally is
growing rapidly
as we're able to speak
more openly about it
from course today with kind of
the public engagement team from maritime
uk
through to
high value high value manufacturing
catapult through to all sorts of
businesses this is the site that is
genuinely genuinely attractive high
quality interest which is great to see
and as far as it will also be delving
more deeply into the accuracy as the
costs afford
[Music]
as part of that we are now talking about
a 17 million pound total project um
which will require
support from members data for that 10
cents and requisite match that is
demanded by the london upfront without
which we cannot continue
and yes at the same time when we're
talking about
project that will
reap
about 65 million
in direct benefits
and that's before
and linked to that kind of final point
there
significant clustering opportunities
as we look further down the line to
ensure that actually we're providing
appropriate land
to be able to deliver on the
furnace of growth spaces
and without achieving
a 2.8 to 1
benefit cost ratio
the gateway criteria is two to one
so again that really puts us in a strong
position
again people have asked a number of
times in terms of uh some of the content
that's included in there
including for example the inclusion
change the places facility
[Music]
around the building's um
net zero credentials which is something
that we're definitely pushing hard to
achieve
um there will be a significant amount of
renewable energy generated through the
building as well
but also we're aware that we're going to
be creating a space for
innovative advanced
work and so making sure that
a suitable electrical connection to
the building is absolutely
as outlined in the report we have
identified a number of family sources
from within
existing council and resources
obviously to maximize
potential viability of the center the
less borrowing that we have to put
forward
the better
um
it's outlined in the
report the opportunity to adapt the use
of the job creation fund
to really maximize those quality
high-paid high-skilled jobs but also to
stimulate the supply chain benefits to
hold down so this isn't just
um about those few who can access those
really high paid roles
but actually spiraling about all the way
down through the system and creating
better employment for all
we are thankfully able to include land
value in there but there does still
remain um
the
requirements for public works leading
board
which obviously comes down with the
interest repercussions
leading to as mentioned in the bid last
time uh
was a
15 i was picked up as a 15 million pound
funding boost um actually in total we
asked it's about 15.
[Music]
thank you um you've got uh on the screen
now um a developed floor plan for the um
from the ground floor uh layout for the
site adrian could you get a little bit
closer to the microphone on youtube
thank you
um you have on the screen now the ground
floor layout before the site which has
been developed to demonstrate this
waterfront access to the workshop and uh
tech space on the
key level
um
which uh you can see there is all this
sort of buff colored
elements on the screen and the pink
existing stone uh
ship building
building that that
is being retained for aquaculture
research facilities and then on the far
right hand side the remodeled
entrance into the site which obviously
is greatly needed
[Music]
with the turning circle in the center
that allows asian wheels to
exit and leave the site in a forward
[Music]
laboratories and
some more science related uses and the
universities
and then uh above that again so some
more commercial space on the top floor
which is um
to be let out um with the
smooth areas being available for um
[Music]
so we've obviously been doing quite a
bit of work in the background since we
last presented to you
and um
next slide is to outline what we intend
to do next um to achieve the funding
deadline um of march 2025
and we need to
press on the delivery
and we've been um progressing with
survey work throughout
as you know and we're now at the stage
where we've completed the entire stage
to report
and further design developments
necessary really throughout the
remaining this year if we are to prepare
and submit the planning submission um
that will need to get it and
secured by early 2023
that will then enable us to progress
with detailed design development and
procurement um in order to
actually deliver this within the
deadline required
um
that really needs to progress ahead of
the actual funding decision um if we
were to meet the deadline because of the
overall scale and compare electricity of
the project
which is obviously
means that this design work is at risk
but obviously it brings the site forward
um
for
this use regardless of the bid outcome
to
achieve that we're looking at really
four main phases of work and um
part of that work has started with the
first phase which is the
preparation of the cycle and surveys and
site clearance work which will continue
throughout the remainder of this year
and into early next year and the main
physical work on site will then be the
construction of the new keyboard and
river frontage which will be
during the
spring summer of 2023
and that will then
follow on
with the main structural work to the
ground floor and also off-site modular
fabrication for the first and second
laws which will be throughout the
remainder 23 and 2024
with the final phase being the fit out
and sort of tenant
we were looking at
completion and footage beyond march 2025
we've been looking at the program and
sequencing of work and by using more
off-site modular accommodation
and
off-site modern methods of construction
we can actually bring forward the
completion to the march 2025
so that's that's our kind
um
thank you
you adrian
as mentioned on setting the jungle in
canada council um we've been working
with an external consultant who has
previously designed
the operational models for other
innovation centers in the region to
ensure that
we're not going into this plant that
we're getting
experts
inputs based on other innovation centers
[Music]
to give us a true knowledge of what the
operational income and overheads may
well be
it's also worth pointing out that
all the
industry insight we've had indicates
that
the alignment of factors at millidog is
truly unique
when you're talking about a waterfront
site which as we all know in a
commercial sense waterfront sites in
the northern devon north northern
cornish coast
tend to be more focused on
residential or hospitality definitely
not kind of linked to those traditional
maritime industries
then having the likes of a major shipper
in ireland wolf alongside having
innovation partners within the center
for the two universities
having um private sector spaces
and then having a significant
customer and forth floating offshore
with developers
really does make this space very special
as such the modeling that's been
undertaken we've been looking at a 90
percent steady state obviously
building up
year one year but with the two
university partners and full time in
center from day one
at that rate uh the
innovation center is scheduled to make a
small surplus uh over 25 years and the
consultants that we have worked with and
universities who have a lot of
engagement with businesses are confident
that that rate will be achieved
however
it's important to go into this work and
full understanding that as many
commercial projects there is significant
risk
in volatility
as such modeling has taken place
in two additional scenarios one a
reduction in income from non-core
tenants so not to the universities
to 80
and the other is an increase in
operating costs by 20 percent with the
income remaining the same
in both of those scenarios the
innovation centre would need additional
support for this continued operation
um
but
in worst case scenario
looking at the equipment approximately
35
year
support from torres district council or
from additional funding sources that we
would be looking for
and that's still achieving
the significant
benefits to the region
in terms of going back to the initial
headline figure of the 62 million pound
economic impact from wage uplift and two
and a half million pounds uh uplift from
schools
but it is important that the members are
aware of that risk and it will be
factored
in terms of those additional risks
beyond
that
there are obviously
that meant
a lot of discussion around inflationary
pressures and those material costs
actually and then to edge in a second to
discuss
the nature of the
construction industry at the moment but
also the fact that we will be talking
about this moving forward over the next
couple of years
we have worked very hard on all of these
points to make sure that
active mitigations have been introduced
and obviously i'm not in a position to
uh
prejudge the final one uh as that means
um
but in all the other points we feel that
appropriate steps have been taken to
make sure that the facts and details
that we're putting forward are
wholeheartedly to
uh
just quickly mention about the uh states
of the construction
chris obviously we've reported many
times about construction inflation
[Music]
is to work with our cost consultants and
design team to basically
utilize what
best
insight and construction of intelligence
is available to us at this time
to
utilize
proven
across data from existing
research facilities and higher education
and establishments to actually building
those
real costs into our financial modelling
for this project and then that's enabled
us enable us to be
as realistic
[Music]
percent the total build cost and there
are there will inevitably be
[Music]
challenges and spikes and costs as we go
along but um
that was that we try to remain agile in
our design development and obviously
adjust the design um to
basically value engineer
the scheme as it goes forward to try and
offset any increase in cost with one
particular item against savings which
would possibly identify in others um
hopefully without compromising on the
overall endpoint
so the
message i guess is that we need to be
agile and
flexible enough
[Music]
[Music]
uh for the next slide to give you a
grand reveal of some of the the
fantastic community support that's been
given
and to move on from those slightly kind
of more serious tones and then trying to
read
um
so
but i have to say it's been an absolute
pleasure to
receive the comments that'd be coming in
it's always nerve-wracking as officers
when this kind of project
gets shared
uh and does get more public attraction
be it through social media a bit through
uh
to the print press
but actually there's just been positive
comment after positive comment after
positive comment
one thing that really strikes in my mind
is that uh mildock is believed to be
the first uh the site of the first
shipbuilding activity in appleton
back in 1672
and the sense of pride within a local
community
in
this project really rekindling
[Music]
that sense of our local origins and
local heritage and moving it into a
prosperous future is one that's been
shining out across the disk
and i'll just check that tom hasn't
moved on without any kind of thing again
in which case
can we move on please
again
a second visualization to
share with you
a bit more
visible
but really focusing on that sense of
what a great place to work and what a
great place to see at the heart of our
community and inspire
hopefully many generations to come
[Music]
um
at this point i believe that uh council
james i would like to teach
[Music]
that all right we see the
presentation uh my first thing really is
to thank adrian and particularly chris
for the amount of work they've done on
this it's been phenomenal
and
what i like about what they've done is
that last week some of you know we've
been
chief exec of exeter was explaining over
there driving exeter forward and we
can't compete with that but the thing
that was going forward was the
universities and
[Music]
the inspiration the drive
and so what they've succeeded in with
this project
ignoring the project i'll come to a
minute is that they've brought the
enthusiasm and the drive
a case like exeter that's growing like
that i've got great plans for the future
this is just a little bit of what we're
starting on and so from that respect
from great thanks to president adrian
you see i'm not going to go through the
report
it's all there
um
truly inspirational it combines the fact
that it's an old marine dot
together with the um
in the future together with the wind
turbines that could be in the area the
surface of them and stuff like that so
it's a wonderful project i'm really
pleased to be studying while we're
initiating it i'd like to been studying
when we finish it but that's not going
to happen so
i'd just like to bring the
bring forward the
considerations of the risks associated
with it and also
i'll bring you to the
recommendations and ask that we approve
the recommendations on block as well
both sides
shall we just take some questions
because i'm sure there are some counts
of chrissy next to me
um asked to speak first on this so would
you like to mention that now i'll come
to the answer well yes this is truly
inspirational and it's so good to hear
a positive green message around green
washing there's a lot that about at the
moment can i just ask one thing though
you said that the universities would be
there from day one
but they actually signed any
agreement with us as to that
that's a a very good question and
obviously one that's been at the
forefront of our mind as we've been
progressing this over the last few
months um a lot of the design
development has been specifically in
consultation with the universities and
on the back of that we have their
letters of support
for the proposals and part of what we'll
be looking to achieve in the months
ahead is also converting that into a
written commitment in the form of some
some
you know pre-let agreements to lease so
that we do have
actual commitment to take up the space
prior to
like breaking ground on the site
so will that be before we go to planning
application or what
it will be in paragraph we're looking
[Music]
personally councilman manley yeah mine's
a question for chris i mean yeah i agree
with everyone you know it's such an
inspirational um project it just got to
succeed and go ahead but my one
question is we are submitting a bid for
15.3 million pounds
if that's accepted
and they don't agree with that amount
but they come back with a reduced amount
of ground but where will we stay on them
or if we put in a bid for 15.3 are we
guaranteed 50.
[Music]
i think we
we all know
that
the bidding process
isn't necessarily always as clear as we
would like to be
i think
the level of strategic fits
for this project
at a national
level rather than just kind of a local
level um
means that
it would be very challenging for them
if they came back and said yeah quite
like it but
[Music]
going to give it um
of what you asked for
i think they would need to have very
clear and strong justification
to do that which
none of the
political agencies that we've engaged
with
with support so that be
spartan for international trade
[Music]
transport department for education
this
cuts across
a huge swage of those um ones i think if
we were
looking at a project that was closer to
20 million
at the top
threshold
of the arts
then i think you put yourself
at more risk
of being asked to kind of take a
percentage
decrease
um
that was very much our intention
throughout to make sure that we weren't
pushing those
upper bands
but i really wish i could give you a a
full uh and clear answer and the only
flip side of that kind of caveat to the
answer is to say that
we don't see this as being a one-off
funding bid
that's i think for example
the future high street funds at the
moment
and their large chunk of london has then
stimulated other
parts of funding to be invested into the
same project
so it's about getting that first
ball
rolling
[Music]
and then constantly bringing more and
more funds
but i think i would be very surprised if
offered these funds if it wasn't seen as
a real
government headline and look what we've
delivered
thank you chris uh
now that you have your home purely to to
second the parliament is
[Music]
aspirations here in torridge i just hope
that our mp will speak up for us and
make sure that we actually get the
funding from central government
[Music]
i have spoken to our mp recently about
it who is hugely enthusiastic i know
that when he met with the leader and
officers at the site he was very
enthusiastic about it and
this he believes is a winner he was a
reluctant supporter of the high street
bid which he felt he had to support
because we asked him to support it but
he knew that it was not a strong bit
this he sees in a completely different
category and he is very enthusiastic
about it and he's right up with it so he
doesn't need to be told by you thank you
[Music]
couldn't answer rosemary's question so
well in the application they will put a
question that will say give you a
what-if scenario so they would say if we
reduce this by 10
what would be the number one effect you
would get the opportunity to then
explain that and say well project's not
going to go ahead
so that wasn't lost actually there's one
thing
missing in the
presentation it's a location
plot plan
[Music]
in the report a couple weeks ago i think
um
when we came on the debate into june so
in effect and this apologies and
i i normally get told uh to not talk as
much rather to
[Music]
so
if
you
drive past
the shipyard with the main shipyard on
your right
and you then sweep round and you then
got to the torridge district council
fish stock
on the right again
there's then the second part of the
harlem wolf site which is called newquay
again on your right that's the more open
space where you can see a few buildings
a few small crayons
please
currently used as a parking depot for
our waste and recycling fleet
and as you can see there's a
small slip way in between that and this
is the new key element of parliament
unhelpfully
if you look on os map
it's actually
inaccurately labeled
so on an os map this is labeled as
middle dot
which has caused some previous confusion
from different parties however
this is new key and this is the middle
dock site
thank you christopher
that's the winner
[Music]
my greatest fear was that a little dog
would end up as a
site for luxury housing which would have
really jeopardized uh the horrible war
that shipyard next door with the noise
pollution
a little bit of detail of that
and of course some councils may recall
we did go to a meeting in cedars back to
three years ago now
uh when we were told about how the
science park in exeter actually
was a magnet for drawing in other
related industries and all sorts of
technologies and this could do the same
as a former governor of beautiful
college the thing we should have
fangirled about was the lack of
aspiration for our young people in this
area because there was no examples or
very few examples of what you know
higher education or technical education
could do for your future this is just
what we need it is quite we get it my
big worry is when i see leveling up
already a week passes on the radio when
you don't hear more disappointed areas
they've been promised this and
everything else and we've been through
that process officers have spent many
hours
working up schemes to attract funding
into here only to be dashed
now councilman newton has confidence in
our mp
which for him because i sure as hell
don't
and i would like to see him
actively supporting this not a letter or
two i would like to see his
diary of activity lobbying ministers he
knows how it's done he should do by now
enough to know how to get the money and
how to get it
some mps are good at it others aren't
but he needs to he needs to be reminded
too there is no safety seat left in the
south west put that message across from
councillor newton because i sure as hell
will and and with his support if he did
actually put his finger in and get it
going i think we could achieve this it's
not all the merit there we are a very
poor area we were deprived we need this
and we deserve it more than most other
areas so
let's get on with it thank you
um i just um
i think it sounds absolutely brilliant
and i agree with that and said this
tipsy wise i think
from a university perspective i think
it's so exciting to potentially have
universities based in the area um i
think that'll be amazing um my only
question was so you said you touched on
the works having to be complete by 2025
my only question was if we were running
behind schedule
and like saying that was out there and
if we weren't on target
what would
effectively happen
um and
yeah i mean
i think you know regardless of whether
people believe in that fund or not
[Music]
carry on
that's fine
okay um
[Music]
i was going to say uh in an answer to
that question specifically about not
achieving the deadline um that is
obviously a risk and something that
we've identified in our risk uh register
that will go in as part of it and in the
current
um
climate construction plan particularly
where supply and availability of
materials remains a challenge
that that is a high risk on our radar um
but i think uh from the recent
experience that we've had with projects
if we
um identify that early and we can
communicate the potential for a slippage
to the
[Music]
demonstrate litigation measures and
recovery measures and
[Music]
just like to ask um a very good uh
presentation thank you officers
just about the um the financial course
project consumer that they will problem
page five
ten percent contingency
when is the baseline for that
contingency put in place because cost of
materials has gone up
not so much before christmas but since
april there's been considerable increase
in cost in that time inflation rate
probably less than five percent free
april but i think you're looking at 15
or 20 on most construction materials at
the present moment
so saying you put 10 in there that's
1.644 million
um this contingency how does that get
treated if you should bring the thing in
line on cost do we keep the difference
or does that go back to
seven
[Music]
thank you another good question um i
don't know uh the answer to the latter
part about handing back uh uh funds if
we come in and
that's unfortunately that's not a
position i've ever really been in um
but um
uh
you know it'd be a nice position to be
in and i'm sure there'll be some
interesting discussions about that
actually happening but to um deal with
the first part of your question really
about the contingency element and it's
really
important when you're building up bits
like this and
you know drilling down into the detail
of the cost that we're not actually
creating a sort of double bubble
situation where we then penalize
ourselves for for actually being over um
cautious in our costs um it's really
important when
building up
the actual build costs that you take
actual historic
cost data
and then use the um rscs building cost
information service to
actually
project those costs forward based on
current trends and based on current
construction inflation profiles and
predictions for the quarter or the years
ahead that you are intending to build
out this project or any project
so that first of all that is um
used as a basis for um the construction
rates that are used to build up the
detailed cost plan for this project once
you've done that you then apply the the
10 um contingency to that so that you
are
in fact working with the most realistic
rates that you can for the
project and really the contingency is
items you know if there's a major
problem in the ground that we
[Music]
involved completely unforeseen
additional expenditure that's really
what the contingency should be used for
not as a bit of working points to deal
with any things
[Music]
thank you chair
sure wants to come in before you cancel
jones and hopefully you'll be the last
one so very quickly to come back i mean
in my experience if if um we are lucky
enough to be under budget we wouldn't
keep those funds those funds would
either not be drawn down or return to
government the skill will come in being
as close to budget as possible so that's
that's the project manager's skill if
you say you're under budget i've seen
the pigs fly over
[Music]
thank you jones
thank you chad i think councillor
christie raised a very good question
about the commitment from the
universities as i think everyone seems
to have realized it seems those are big
partners who are really going to drive
this
forward
and in the
financial
information you get we talked about how
um the cost of the council if the
commercial
letting side of it then was was to be
not optimum
what about if the universities
decide that they don't want to continue
anymore are the universities going to be
tied in for 25 years or are they going
to be able to get out quite easily so
that's just my my concern is if we lose
those partners
are we going to be able to sustain this
going forward i think what's really
interesting is that there's uh what
you're asking what it was a very good
question uh three of us were leaping
forwards to respond because it's
something that we've discussed and
explored at great lengths uh i will
merrily delegate this one to the head of
communities in places
more than usual yeah
we touched on earlier on with those
negotiating negotiations to be had but
obviously our intention would be to tie
them in for as long as we can to give us
that certainty because it is a risk um
and
i think the bigger risk for us at the
moment as it's moving forward
for people to do that i don't think that
they want you know they want security
and tenure as well so i think those
negotiations will progress well
but the bigger miss for us will be the
other letter we face i think that's
going to be the more fluid element of
the project but the demand that's being
shown so far and chris has got it coming
out is
you know
these innovation centers
you've got people clamoring to actually
be a part of that and
to actually book
office space workshop space design space
whatever and i think
you know hopefully when this when this
comes to fruition it's going to be
such a success we will be in that
position so if you've got one university
that you know decides to put out for
whatever reason i think you'll have
others that will be jumping on the
bandwagon so you know i think it's uh
extremely positive looking forward
one thing i didn't know adrian's gonna
have a lot of work with his hands over
the next couple of years because we've
got this center we've got the
environmental center which probably is
going to end up being built for us at
the same time so
good luck to you aj
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded
can we put that to the vote please that
we're all in support of this
[Music]
[Music]
thanks members so it's just a a brief
um explanation as we discussed earlier
you've got an item in part one and an
item in part two in relation to housing
so i don't i don't i'm sure i don't need
to tell anybody that
the housing market locally and across
the country is uh challenging if not uh
housing crisis as i'm often referred to
um we all know housing is a very complex
area and that this can't be any single
impact or single intervention uh that
will make things better on a very quick
intermediate basis
so members are aware it's in your
strategic plan it's one of your high
priorities for the council to deliver
some interventions particularly around
affordable housing for our local
residents and our communities
we know there's many
themes and streams to housing whether
it's uh private ownership private rental
sector social affordable housing holiday
let's airbnbs second homes there's a you
know quite a wide range of things
that need looking at and leads
consideration
so you touched us with
quite a comprehensive
uh action plan and something that uh
john walters updated you and leadership
on a number of occasions and we've also
updated members of full council
those elements of that action plan are
looking at viability assessments through
the planning process
and more directed look at what lands the
council
owns that could
be considered appropriate for
future uh housing provision that's your
part two item later on in the agenda
uh you also asked us to look at and
investigate where there's funding
options to help support your strategy
and also look at
and look towards registered providers
and or debt developers that might help
us in progressing any options further
so we've been working on all those items
and we started putting together a
strategic delivery plan
pulling together those
three out items around our own land
funding options and partnership options
you're also aware there's a significant
uh
challenge in terms of homelessness and
that's been added as a separate theme to
the
housing strategy to look at uh how we
can manage our temporary accommodation
and hopefully drive down uh our use of
temporary foundation drive down costs so
as i said you go apart when i turn which
is that and
reported earlier that there's uh some
commercial insensitivity around some of
the the council land review and what
we'd hoped then to do after moving into
part two and having some discussions is
be able to come back into part one the
open part of the agenda uh for you to
make certain decisions there are certain
aspects and due to that sensitivity that
need to be debated in part two uh first
of all to chair someone intended to say
say at that point
thank you steve okay so we're moving
then to
item eight nine
which is uh requires us to move into
part two because there are
confidential information to be discussed
survivor of the builder mr james
that's about the second here all in
favor please
again
abstentions